Now the message where why when I read
the story I have to fight back
tears and if I read Job I'll be crying
honestly it's too hard for me to read
these stories and not cry
because he's too
beautiful. But anyway, let me try to
finish the story. I don't want to get
there yet. So what did God do? He proved
his love to them, right? He proved his
love. Created Adam perfect. Showed up to
Adam. Gave him the animals. Adam,
they're yours. Gave him a wife. They're
seeing God. God did nothing but show
them love, right? He proved to them he
loves them and wants what's best for
them, right? Cuz look, if God was
selfish, he wouldn't say, "It's not good
for man to be alone. I'll make a
member." See, he's concerned.
Adam, I see you're alone and I'm going
to make a helper for you cuz so he
proved his love for them.
Right? But what was the message now?
Adam, I've gone out of my way to tell
you trust me. You don't have to
learn on your own. You don't have to do
things on your own to learn. Trust me to
tell you what's right and obey me cuz I
have shown you. I love you. I don't want
to hurt you. I want what's best for you.
So take me at my word. So Adam, here's
the test. That tree of the knowledge of
good and evil. If you eat that tree, you
know what you're saying to me? You know
what you're saying to me? God, I don't
trust you enough to tell me how to run
my life. I'm going to do it my way. I'm
going to learn on my own what is good
and right. I will determine what is good
and right for myself. No, Adam, you
don't want to do
that. Believe me, you don't want to do
that, Adam. I know what's best for you.
So, then here's the
betrayal. A serpent shows out of
nowhere. Here's the betrayal. Now,
you're going to see the heart of God and
you're going to see what
Job. A serpent shows out of
nowhere. The serpent whom they don't
know tells them, "God is lying to you.
So, did God really say you shall not eat
of any tree of the garden seed? First
lie. God didn't say that. See, this is
what Satan does. He first gets you to
doubt God's word. And he gets you to
doubt God's faithfulness. You really
trust him. You think he's telling you
the truth? He's lying to you. He's
jealous of you. He doesn't want what's
best for you. He wants slaves that he
can control.
See? And so when he said to her, first
doubt, did God say you shall not eat
from any tree of the garden? Now look,
she's going to testify against herself.
The woman said to the servant, "From the
fruit of the trees of the garden we
make." No, no, no. He said, "We can eat
it
all. All of it, but from the fruit of
the trees in the midst of the garden,"
God said, "You shall not eat from it.
You shall not touch it, lest you die."
Now watch. The serpent said to the
woman, "You surely shall not die." See,
you believe him.
You really believe? He's lying. He knows
you're not going to die. He doesn't want
you to eat because he doesn't want you
to be like him. He doesn't want you to
have knowledge like him to know what's
right or wrong for
yourself. See, you surely will not die.
For God knows in the day you eat from
it, your eyes will be open. You'll be
like God, knowing good and see. No, he
knows you're going to be like him.
You're going to be knowledgeable like
him. You're going to be able to know
right and wrong. So, you don't need him
to tell you. See, this was the
attack. You don't need God to tell you
what's best for you. You can do it on
your own. And you know when the betrayal
is she believed a serpent whom she did
not know and disbelieved the God who had
done nothing but prove his love for
her. That's the betrayal. When she ate
of the tree, you know what she told God?
I don't trust you. I don't think you're
good and I don't think you have my best
interest. This stranger whom I don't
know, I believe him over against you.
Even though you proved your love for me
by creating all this for me, I still
don't trust
you. She broke the heart of God. Because
you know what that means? Imagine you,
your friend. I'm going to go into Job.
So this was the story. Imagine your
friend, your buddy.
You have done nothing but been good to
him and you prove you loved him and a
stranger comes and he says a few words
about you and your friend now takes the
word of the stranger and betrays you.
What would you do do that? What would it
do to your heart?
Destroy it in two. Just that's what Adam
and Eve did to God. You know what they
told God? We don't trust you. And his
heart broke.
This is why I say when you understand
the story, it was a story of trust.
Adam, will you trust me? Will you take
because I proved my love for you. What
more could I have done for you? I gave
you the world. I gave you the animals.
You could eat anything you want. I even
gave you this
woman. What
more could I have done?
to prove my love for
you. So this why when I read it because
you know why we're all Adam and Eve to
this day when we do things our way.
We're telling God yes to the serpent, no
to you because I don't trust you to tell
me what's best for me. So I'm Adam all
over again. So this is the story of the
garden. But now watch how much he loves
them. Look how much he loves them. He
still doesn't want to give up on them.
Because remember he told Adam, "The day
you eat of it, you shall die." He said,
"But he didn't
die." You know
why? Because the serpent said, "You're
not going to die." Almost seems like God
was lying. The serpent. You know
why? God loved Adam and Eve so much, he
could not allow himself to kill them and
put them to death. No, I can't.
My love for you is so great. I can't see
you die. So what did he do? Look what he
did. Look at his heart after doing that.
Look, he shows up. Why didn't he show up
before? Because he was allowing Adam to
make a choice. He could have showed up
and stopped the serpent. No, this is
your time to shine. This is the time for
you to make a choice and show Satan and
the world you trust me and you won't
take a word of a stranger over against
me because you've seen how good I am to
you. But Adam, you failed
me. You put your wife ahead of me and
she tra tr trust a stranger over against
me. Did the serpent give you the garden?
No. Did the serpent make you a wife? No.
Did the serpent give you control over
the animals? No. Who did it? I did. But
this is how you repay
me. This is how you repay me. But then
look at his heart. Now when they ate,
they realized they're naked. So they try
to cover themselves. Then they heard the
the sound of God walking around. Now
before this, when God showed up, they
would run to him. Like when you have
children and you walk in the house and
your children run to you excited to see
you. Now they're running away from him.
Look, the God whom they couldn't wait to
see and they run to him like children
because they were children. Now when
they hear him, they run away from him.
See, that's what Satan does. Satan wants
to destroy you in your sin to make you
feel so guilty and disgusted that you're
embarrassed and ashamed to face your
father again.
and he wins because look, they ran. Then
they heard the sound of Yahweh God
walking in the garden cool of the day
and the man and his
wife hid themselves in the face of
Yahweh God. When they knew God was
coming, they would run to him. Bobby,
Bobby, because the Bible says Adam's the
son of God. Luke 3:38. Hey, Eve, God is
here. Our father's here. and they'd run
to him happy to see him. Now when God
shows up, he sees them running away from
him. You understand the knife in his
heart. To see your children embarrassed
and running away from you. That's the
parents worst
nightmare. And here's
God looking at Adam and
Eve. And they're running away from him.
What happened, Adam? What happened? Why
are you running from me?
Yahweh God called to the man and said,
"Where are
you? Where are you?" And God knows
because I'll show you. When God asks
questions, it's not because he doesn't
know. It's because to show give you
opportunity to confess, acknowledge so
he can forgive you. And when you don't,
then he says, "You see, look how evil
you've become that even when I ask you
to come clean." It's like when you tell
your son, "Son, did you go into the
closet when I told you not to?" You
know, he did. Why are you asking to see
if your son's going to get right? And
he's asking Adam, why are you running
from me? What happened, Brun? What
happened? And he said, I heard the sound
of your garden and I was afraid because
I was naked, so I hid. You're afraid of
me now. This is the same God that you
couldn't get enough of and you would run
to my arms and you were excited to now
you're afraid and you're running from
me. And he said, "Who told you that you
are
naked? Have you eaten from the tree
which I command you not to eat?" Now
watch the blame blame. This is us. So
when I confront you with your sin? Yeah,
but because so and so did such and
such. We play we play the blame game. We
don't take responsibility. I don't I'm a
sinner. I'm wicked. Look, the woman whom
you gave to be with me. See, it's not my
fault. That woman that you gave me, she
gave me from the tree to eat. So now the
blame game he doesn't take
responsibility. So God says see Adam you
failed. I want you to see that even when
I confront you instead of coming clean
and saying I'm sorry
Babi my father I have sinned against you
forgive me you now put the blame game.
Well if you didn't give her to me I
wouldn't be in this mess. He's blaming
God. I want you to see pay attention.
The woman whom you gave to be with me.
See he's blaming him. In other words, if
you didn't give me this woman, I
wouldn't be in this
mess. Out of my kindness and love, I
gave you a partner. Now you throw it in
my
face. Doesn't that sound like some of
our friends when we do them a favor and
things go around, then they throw it in
our
face? Have that happened to
you? It happened to God before it
happened to you. Adam is throwing in his
face. Well, the woman you gave me. Oh,
so now you're blaming me when I saw you
alone and I didn't want you to be alone
because my heart was hurting for you and
I gave you a helper and now you're
throwing that in my face, my
kindness. See, no
repentance, none blame game. What about
Eve? Did she say, "Yes, Bobby, my
father, I sinned. I shouldn't have done
this to Adam. I shouldn't have." Then
Yahweh God said to the woman, "What is
this? Have you done?" Blame game. The
serpent deceived me I ate. Oh, so you
too, huh? You're not going to take
responsibility. That's why he goes
straight to condemn the serpent. Notice
he didn't ask the serpent because he was
not going to give the serpent a second
chance. He went straight to judgment.
You because you did this, this what I'm
do to you. But with Adam and Eve, he
didn't want to do
that. With Adam and Eve, he wanted to
show them even
now I love you so much that I'll forgive
you if you confess. But you didn't
confess.
What happened to you? How did you go
from running to my arms? How did you go
from being excited to see me, happy to
see me, and now running from me, hiding
from me, and lying to me? And come, what
happened? Did I not tell you, trust me?
I know what's best for you. You see what
the tree did to
you? Why couldn't you just trust me?
Why couldn't you take me at my word?
Look what you did. Look at the misery
now. Now, Adam, because of what you did,
death will enter the world. Because of
what you did, children will be born sick
and diseased because of what you did.
Parents will have to bury their
children. If you had just listened to
me, none of this would have
happened. No parent would have to bury
their children. No spouse would have to
bury their husband or wife. No child
would have to see their parents die.
Look what you did because you did not
trust me and take me at my word.
Why? Why? But notice he still doesn't
give up on them. What he says, he gives
them hope because remember he said the
day you eat shall die. Look at the hope.
Yahweh God said the serpent because you
have done this you are cursed. Now I
have a series explaining what this
means. I can't explain it now. Just take
it for what it is. It's actually Satan
described as an animal. But here's where
they heard hope. Remember, they said,
"The day we eat, we're going to die."
Watch the heart of God. And this is
going to show you Jesus. I will put
enmity, hatred between you and the
woman. Ah, I'm going to make you now
hate the woman. I'm going to make the
woman hate you. The very woman that you
deceived, you're going to be enemies.
and between your seed and her seed, her
children. He her seed that will come
from her will crush your head. You shall
bruise his heel. Now, you know when he
said that, you know what he just told
Adam and
Eve? You know, he told them, "You're not
going to die." Why? Because they didn't
have any seed
yet. They didn't have children. But in
telling the serpent her seed, they heard
it. He was basically telling him, "Adam,
Eve, you're not going to die this
day. She will have
seed. She will have an offspring, and
that offspring will crush and destroy
the serpent." So, in saying that, he
gave them hope. Uh-oh, God is not going
to strike us dead. And more hope. Here's
the other one. I will greatly multiply
your pain and conception and pain you
children. So, now they know, all right,
we're not going to die. We're going to
have kids.
Okay, we're going to have kids. Wow. So,
God is not going to strike us dead. He
said he would. Why? Because this is
another teaching from God. I'm going to
show it to you. So, I hope you don't
mind. I'm taking time to unpack this. I
want you to learn. You young men, you
got to learn this. In pain, you'll bear
children. Your desire will be for your
husband, and he will roll roll over you.
I'm going to come back and man, I'm
going to explain this. Huh? This affects
relationships. I'm going to explain this
right after this. Now to Adam he said
because you've listened to the voice of
your wife. So you chose your voice o
your wife over me. You put her ahead of
me and that's another sin. You can never
put anyone ahead of God because without
God you wouldn't have anyone. Without
God I wouldn't have my
daughters. So it's an insult to God when
I put my daughters ahead of him. God's
going to say without me you wouldn't
have these kids. Now you're going to
love them more than me and put them
ahead of me. So that's what he's saying
to Adam. Adam, I gave you this woman,
but you put her ahead of me. You would
rather see her happy and break my heart
than say, "No, don't eat because we
can't sin against our father. How are we
going to hurt our
father?" You are more concerned about
making her happy. Even though you knew
it'd break my
heart, you listen to the evil I told you
not to do. I command you, saying, "You
shall not eat from it. curse it is the
ground because of you and pay pain you
will eat all the days of your life. So
he's saying you're not going to die
today. You will die but not today. You
won't die until you have children so
that the human race isn't wiped out
because then he says because you came
from the ground you will return to the
ground. That's why we
die. You want to know why we die? It's
right there. I did not create you to
die, Adam. But now you can't live in
this body, this body that's now wicked
and sinful and decaying. You can't live
like that forever. You will return to
the dust. And a day will come when Jesus
returns and he'll make all things new.
But until then, you can't live forever
in these kind of bodies. There's no way
you're going to live forever in bodies
that are getting old, decaying, and
doing evil. It's not going to
happen. This life of yours has to end
eventually.
Now, but God said they're going to die,
but they didn't
die. These two verses, I'm going to
explain it. So, give me 10 more minutes
with this. We'll talk about Job if
you're interested. Now, the man called
his wife's name Eve. Now, if you don't
know what Eve means, and the hud the
Hebrew
language means life. Now, here's what's
ironic. He called their life. What life?
You just brought death because they
understood. When Adam heard God that
from the woman would come the seed. See,
he's listening. I will put hatred
between you and the woman, between your
seed and her seed. And that seed will
crush the serpent. He knew, wow, the
hope for mankind, the hope that man will
live again is going to come from the
woman. So he called her life because she
was the mother of all the living. See,
Adam realized God is not going to strike
us dead. He just gave us hope that from
the woman will come salvation from
death. And that's why he called her
because he said her. Notice he didn't
say the seed of the
man. And here's what God did. This is
going to point to Jesus. Now I'm going
to connect it with Jesus. Huh? Then I'm
going to go to Job. I'm going connect it
with Jesus. Then Yahweh made garments of
skin for Adam and his and his wife and
he clothed them. Notice when they
realized they were naked, they took fix
and they made themselves aprons and they
hid. God could still see their
nakedness. It wasn't until he clothed
them that they were no longer
naked. Do you
understand? When they tried to cover
themselves, he could still see their
shame. He then clothed them. But notice
he clothed them with garments of skin.
He had to find skin to make them
clothing. Well, they're the only human
beings. Where do you think he got the
skin from?
Animals. He had to kill an animal for
them to be
saved. There's pointing to Jesus. Even
though I said you would die, but I love
you too much. I don't want you to die.
So I will allow someone to die in your
place so you can live. And here's now
picture to Christ. This animal dies so
you can be clothed because this animal
is going to point to Jesus, the lamb of
God who will die the death we all
deserve so we can live forever.
Amen. So he just gave them the gospel.